are three products you don't need to
splurge on I'm Dr Shaw and this is
glamorous skinfo let's get into it
cleansers cleansers are something you
use every single day so if you have an
expensive cleanser it's going to get
costly pretty quickly look for gentle
cleansers that have hydrating
ingredients that don't strip Your Skin
Barrier my favorite product is the
CeraVe hydrating cream to foam cleanser
it's really for all skin types micellar
water this is really effective to remove
makeup but you don't need an expensive
product look for something under 15
pounds like the La Roche Posay micellar
water moisturizers so there's actually a
study that shows that more expensive
moisturizers are more likely to contain
common allergens so look for something
that's fragrance free that has ceramides
and something that's actually going to
help restore a healthy Skin Barrier